Latest news on April 1st, 2024
nationalist parties may gain in European Parliament elections
but face unity challenges over Ukraine
affecting European political dynamics.
Tragic balcony collapse at Turkish
CHP election Celebration in dennysley
results in one death and multiple injuries.
Amid parties national success,
Pakistani court suspends former Prime Minister
Imran Khan's graft conviction.
14 year sentence pending appeal amidst ongoing legal challenges.
Israeli forces arrest Hamas leader Ismail Haniah's sister in Telshiba
for alleged incitement of terrorism
as part of a broader anti terrorism effort.
If you enjoy my video,
please give me a like and subscribe to my channel. Thank you.